two spinners each arrow is spun once the
score is the total of the two numbers
shown by the arrows and this table down
here shows all scores that can be
obtained so down here you can see this
what's its called again if it's all
possible things
it's a sepsis very good this table
values shooting simple fish okay notice
how these numbers in the table are found
the words tell you the score is the
total the two numbers so that's why for
example of spinner B has one and spinner
a has three then their total is four
that's not crazy okay so you see how I'm
reading this the game could have been
different
maybe the game could have been the the
score is the difference between those
two scores or the score is the product
you multiply them together and I would
just get different things in here okay
it starts off nice and gentle what's the
value of x in the table if it's just two
plus three so we'll just say five I
might as well put five there as well now
that we know what the answer is yes
sorry I'm cheating okay all right let's
get going you're going walk through with
me what's the probability of obtaining a
score less than four well this is just
the fraction favorableness divided by
total possible right so you can you've
already counted them up haven't you
these are all of the ones in fact I'm
just going to highlight them yet you can
see this that there's a six outcomes and
what's the size of the sample space
twelve
we're really stressed for their six out
of 12 which of course is a half okay so
you can go ahead and write both of those
so I'll get my head either way there you
go so six out of 12 is a half six out of
12 is fine though you clearly
demonstrated the skill that this
question is about a lot about fractions
it's about understanding the situation
okay now this one requires a little more
thought think with me about this on
spinner br-2 is obtained just pause then
the situation has now changed not
everything that I had written before is
possible now I've limited I place the
condition on the probability of this
event so which one's better be it's on
at the time right so therefore I know
that this is the case here I know that
this has happened I can ignore all the
other options for spin a bit what's the
probability of seeing a score of 3 well
just like before just like before the
probability is favorable outcomes
divided by total possible how many times
is it possible to get 3 here and here
how many are there that are possible now
because I know spinner B has to have a 2
on it therefore there's only really
three options so it's 2 out of 3
does that make sense so you can see
where I've got and why I keep going back
to this fraction favourable events total
possible ok here comes the financial
expectation at least play the game using
the spinners with the following
financial outcomes and you can see them
all written there ok now before we move
on past this point lists I want you to
see that all those dot points are
scaffolder and what we previously saw so
we already know what the probability of
obtaining a score less than 4 is it's a
half right
so therefore this probability here is a
half can you see a score of less than 4
so we've already worked this out how
many ways are there to score 4 exactly
there are 4 ways
out of 12 because I look up the top and
I counted one two three four ways to
score four does that make sense
and they're twelve possible and then
that leaves me with lose three dollars
for a score of more than four so what's
the probability this time so the top
five and six are it probability equals 2
out of 12 okay now what are we going to
do have I got some space on here yeah I
do okay we're going to work out the
financial excitation and then we're
going to use that to answer this
question here which is justify it's not
find a number it's user number to make
an argument okay so bless you financial
expectation now earlier I said to you
financial expectation is just a money
version of expected value that's true
but with a slight difference which I'm
about to show you in this question okay
so look carefully there are three
options so we're going to do probability
value probability value probability
value let's work it out for over 12
which is 1/3
what's that multiplied by what's the
value in this case $12 good I'm going to
start summing I'm going to start adding
1/2 is the probability of look carefully
really nothing so I'm going to put $0
now this is not going to contribute
anything to my final answer but it's
important you put that down because
these question is worth three marks and
they've asked you to justify the answer
you're going to end up with with
suitable calculations so you're showing
that you know where financial
expectation comes from last bit to out
of 12 times what good so this is more
for three dollars okay so net negative
three okay now that's the sum of
everything but but this game is not free
the game is not free
okay so seeing as this game is not free
right imagine just imagine it's not
actually one of the possibilities but
suppose she wins five dollars in the
game suppose there's some simple game
where there's our one hundred percent
chance that you'll win five dollars but
it costs five dollars to play think
about this non-rhetorical question what
is the financial expectation zero you're
going to pay your five bucks and then
you're going to get it back so your net
result is you break even okay that's the
phrase you would actually use
so therefore along here I need to
include so here all of my probabilities
and values probabilities and values and
then right on the end here as a separate
thing I have to take away five dollars
because that's the cost of the game okay
and as you see later on well
most games have a cost right so now
let's go ahead and let's work this out
four twelve twelve dollars is $4 1/2 of
zero dollars is still zero dollars and
that's going to be yeah 50 Cent's isn't
it
but it'll be minus all of that and then
I take away the $50 sorry $50 cents an
expensive game I take away the $5 that
it costs to play the game so you can see
the total final financial expectation is
going to be okay does this make sense
you see how I've crunched the numbers
and you can see where things come from
you may like to well I'll come back to
this in a second here are your
probabilities of events times the value
of the events and then over here it's
super important that you label this so
you know what that number says well this
is the cost of the game okay now we need
to conclude will the lease expect again
or a loss and how much will it be
she should expect a loss and that that
word is important that you include and
you don't just leave your answer as as
that at least
should expect you lose and we already
have this number which they asked us for
up here how much will it be per game now
um it was raised before word back a bit
of a depressing outcome isn't it that's
true guess what if you go into any
casino the financial expectations for
every single game will be negative if
it's positive never they've messed up
right because the intent is for you to
go there and lose money now a dollar
fifty per game is actually quite a lot
casinos and gambling industry in general
is in the interest of making this low
enough that you'll keep playing but high
enough that they'll actually make a
profit out of you in a reasonable time
okay and this is how people get addicted
to gambling because they'll play ten
games they'll win $100 once and then
they'll lose one hundred and two dollars
over that time